[Musique]
la 5e édition du festival graffiti a
débuté début octobre avec une vingtaine
d'artistes de la Réunion et d'ailleurs
le festival s'est associé à l'Académie
des camélias pour promouvoir le
développement durable dans le cadre d'un
nouveau projet bien plus vaste ce projet
fait partie d'un d'un projet plus vaste
qui est mondial c'est-à-dire que il y a
il va y avoir 17 artistes dans 17 pays
différents qui vont travailler sur les
17 hommes de des odd du développement
durable des thèmes qui ont été mis en
place par les Nations Unies donc du coup
la Réunion est la 9e destination c'est
un projet qui a vu le jour parce que
j'ai rencontré la la fondatrice de ce
projet donc Zaira MITI qui habite à
Dubaï ça a commencé à Dubaï alors je
l'ai rencontré au festival d'Ar
contemporin descort et parce que j'ai
participé à ce projet là-bas donc je
leur ai dit de venir à La Réunion dans
le festival réunion graffiti donc le but
en fait c'est
que installé ici à l'Académie des
camélias les artistes peignent des 17
toiles et on sert en gros de prétexte
prétexte pardon pour que des des
scolaire ou le public Vienne découvrir
le travail des
associations des associations qui
travaillent sur le développement durable
à la Réunion on est un peu une porte
d'entrée en fait on est vraiment un
prétexte pour ça pour pouvoir mettre en
avant ce qui se passe à la réunion sur
le développement durable et ceris sur le
gâteau ces toiles vont être exposé à
Dubaï pendant la COP 28 donc nous ça
nous permet de mettre en avant les
artistes
en fait du streetart qu'on en les
exposant là-bas à Dubaï l'Académie des
camélias accueille de nombreux scolaires
et parmi eux la classe oxygène du
collège
Montgaillard le collège Montgaillard et
la classe oxygène sont des élèves que
nous accompagnons vers plus de réussite
éducative et qui sont ciblés par le
corps enseignant pour faire des
activités sportives et culturelles et
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du festival
réunion
ces élèves viennent participer aux
différentes activités et ce dispositif
est cofinancé par le département de La
Réunion et il permet vraiment à ses
élèves de sortir des murs de l'école et
B de faire connaissance avec des
éducateurs professionnels de l'éducation
populaire des artistes et ben voilà pour
pouvoir leur permettre de se
décloisonner tout simplement et de voir
autre chose que ce qu'il voit
habituellement Milie
la collectivité départementale participe
à ce projet en finançant l'envoi des 17
toiles à
Dubaï